stay away for me she's in the battle
dimension they have to go in and get her
back the down dimension doesn't function
like the real world navigate through
this place we're gonna have to use our
imagination
Walter Walter great no I define Diana on
my own in an alternate-dimension run on
it nagging me yes it did work when I did
the Mario wait how have we gotten this
far into Mario Mei and not talked about
the game why am I still wearing this
stupid mustache my name is Walter
benezia for months I was trapped in the
evil Dino Roth's dial dimension a place
where I was duplicated dozens of times
eventually I managed to escape but now
Dinah Rob is sending his army to take me
back with the help of my friends he
fight them off and hope to ultimately
take down mr. rage dinosaur the more we
countdown the weaker he gets this is
top-5
the first Super Mario Bros game was
released in 1985 for the NES designed by
Shigeru Miyamoto and Takashi Tezuka this
game started one of the most
recognizable and beloved side-scrolling
franchises Mario games generally follow
our titular character Mario and some of
his family and friends as they fight to
defend the Mushroom Kingdom from the
evil Bowser they also have become an
integral part of the Nintendo brand
becoming synonymous with the company
there has been a Mario game released for
every system that Nintendo has put out
there are so many great titles that
involve Mario although he is a plumber
we've seen Mario be many things a tennis
player go-kart racer even a doctor
choosing between all of those games
would be one difficult challenge so for
this list we're going to stick with the
core Mario games these are the top 5
best Super Mario Brothers games
yeah there must be still counting down
the warp pipes gone going down do we get
more for top
[Music]
man number five super mario 64 when
super mario 64 was released in 1996 it
not only revolutionized the mario
franchise but also 3d gaming for years
to come the game gracefully transitioned
the traditional 2d platformer into a 3d
sandbox world developers did a great job
bringing Mario's adventures and spirit
into the third dimension players were
challenged to click stars after
completing tasks and levels since it was
a 3d game there was more emphasis placed
on exploring courses rather than
directing the player through them
I remember being absolutely amazed the
first time I was able to begin exploring
Peach's castle it was a cool experience
to finally be free to roam the world of
Mario in mario 64
Princess Peach has once again been
kidnapped by Bowser in order to save her
players had to explore different levels
by jumping into paintings or hidden
walls to take them to different worlds
there was obvious care taken by the
designers with this game some of the
small details are what really make it
special players are even introduced to
their cameraman in the beginning of the
game now I will admit some parts of this
game have not aged well the graphics
don't look so great anymore but a
younger me will always remember how
stunning those graphics were in the
mid-90s the camera mechanics at the time
were revolutionary
it was one of the first games to offer
players the opportunity to control the
camera to get different angles so the
modern gamer these controls may seem
clunky and frustrating but 3d gaming as
we know it today wouldn't exist without
some of the innovations that originated
from mario 64 despite its flaws it is
undeniably one of the most important
games in the franchise maybe one of
these paintings could we meet Ayane
number four Super Mario Galaxy
after the relative flop of mario
sunshine people were skeptical of the
next open world 3d Mario game galaxy
released for the Wii in 2007 blasted
these expectations into space literally
Princess Peach's castle has been
completely ripped out of the ground and
lifted into space by Bowser in a giant
flying saucer I'm not kidding
that's really how the game starts Mario
is then launched into space with the
help of some magic where he meets
Rosalina who will help him on his
journey to save the princess each galaxy
that Mario visits is made of small
planetoid
every planet offers new puzzles and
challenges making the game feel fresh
and exciting with the discovery of each
planetoid players were challenged to use
gravity to help solve puzzles and
complete levels Mario could even orbit
planets and fling himself through space
to the next one Super Mario Galaxy tried
to play with the idea of having
spherical platforming levels to offer a
new dimension and innovation to the
world of 3d platformers the game looks
beautiful it also used some unique
features of the weave without it feeling
forced or clumsy overall the game was
well designed and engaging exactly what
was needed to revitalize 3d Mario games
and launch them into greatness once
again
number three Super Mario Odyssey the
most recent installment in the Mario
franchise has left some fans in awe the
sheer scope of this game is massive it
is truly a sandbox game as players
explore the different worlds they
seamlessly move from one level to
another this creates a fully immersive
experience there is so much to explore
it's addictive to try and collect all of
the power moons one of the most
innovative additions to this game is
Mario's hat happy with Cappy players can
control different enemies and others
offering new ways to play levels and
allowing access to areas Mario is unable
to get to himself Mario Odyssey is the
full realization of the potential first
showed to fans in Mario 64 it's almost
worth buying the switch just to
experience this game and breath of the
wild of course number 2
Super Mario Bros 3 the game that find
franchise when Super Mario Bros 3 came
out for the NES in 1990 it changed the
world of Mario
the game was expansive by standards at
the time playing it felt like a truly
special experience it was creative and
ambitious the graphics showed the power
of the NES system the math felt alive
with motion one of the most astounding
things about Super Mario Bros 3 was how
fresh every level felt each world was
uniquely designed with levels that
challenged players to think in creative
ways the gimmicks and powers that were
introduced were perfectly played they
were never overdone this gave the game a
great flow and challenged to it Super
Mario 3 also introduced some of the most
famous Mario power-ups such as the
Tanooki suit and frog suit it is
honestly just one of the most creative
games that I've ever played
it is a wonderful game and one of the
best platforming games ever made
[Music]
Chuck never fails
and the number one bet Super Mario game
in super mario world if Super Mario Bros
3 define the franchise Super Mario World
show fans but the franchise truly could
be Super Mario World is one of the first
games on the SNES Nintendo knew they
needed a stellar game to give Vince
people that they needed to upgrade from
the NES to the SNES this game definitely
delivered it expanded the world even
farther than its predecessor Super Mario
Bros 3 did this was partly due to the
fact that there was now a save feature
players no longer had to beat the game
in one sitting
rather they could save their progress
and return after mulling over a
particularly challenging level and the
levels on this game are truly
challenging at times
although the developers took away some
of Mario's powers from Super Mario Bros
3 they gave us the wonderful gift of
Yoshi that's right this was Yoshi's
first appearance at a Mario game another
interesting aspect of this game is the
secrets and different exits it added two
levels there were sometimes countless
different ways to complete a level that
could take players to new areas or
unlock different areas there are many
people who revere this game as one of
the best games ever made
it is well worth your time to play it
even now for a challenging immersive and
creative gaming experience
I wonder if there's a secret passage
that could lead me to Ayane here
[Music]
[Applause]
you